- You better hit those drums, Lester!
(Kelly laughs)
(audience clapping)
Welcome back.
Some of my favorite
stories I saved for last.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
I love this next video
which comes from my home state of Texas.
Seriously, the Fort
Worth Police Department
created probably the greatest
recruitment video of all time.
Just look.
- Well howdy folks.
Officer Big B here.
Are you looking for a new job?
Are you ready to try something new
that'll make a difference at
doing something really great?
Well, come join us here at the
Fort Worth Police Department.
We're hiring and we got it all.
We got your patrol vehicles,
we got your explorers,
we got your Tahoes, and we
even got your F-150 Responders.
Say what?
Now currently, you may not have squat,
but come join us here at the
Fort Worth Police Department
because we've got SWAT.
- You gotta see the whole video.
Officer Big B,
also known as Officer Buddy Calzada
is on the line right now.
Oh my God, I love you so much.
(audience cheering)
- Oh boy, it was really fun.
- You are like my
favorite what I'm liking.
Okay, where did you get this idea?
Obviously, from a car
dealership commercial.
It was like amazing.
- Right.
You know, Kelly, we just
wanted to do something
that was fun, that would
catch people's attention.
You know, we've got these cool vehicles,
we've got these mounted horses,
and we just wanted to
make a car commercial
that just looked fun to everybody.
And I'll tell you what, we
went to the chief on this
and he said, "You've never done
anything like this before."
And we're like, "Right,
Chief, we haven't."
And he said, "Let's do it."
And so, I'm not an actor.
I had to memorize all these lines, Kelly.
And we just made the character
of Big B as big as we could.
We wanted to grab everyone's attention
from all kind of cities around
here, including Burleson,
which is about five minutes away from us.
- Yeah, well I was born in Fort Worth
and raised there half my life.
So you are making me proud right now, sir.
You are awesome.
So, has it worked?
Like did you get a lot
of applicants after that?
'Cause it made me think about it.
- Kelly, it's been absolutely amazing.
We had 1,127 applicants
and out of that 232 of those were females.
This job is very serious, but
we wanted people to just know
behind this vest, behind this badge,
there's a human heart
and you can have fun in
every job that you do.
- I love that.
You have the greatest
smile, by the way as well.
Thank you so much, Big B.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
- [Big B] Thank you, Kelly.
- Now I wanna close things up
with something special for one
lucky person in the audience.
Courtesy of our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of The Kelly Clarkson Show.
There is a check for $1,000 from Pilot
under someone's chair in this
audience taped underneath.
Go ahead, look for it.
Go ahead!
(person cheering)
Yeah.
Hello.
- Hello.
- What's your name?
Where are you from?
- My name is Jennifer.
I'm from Monterey Park, California.
- Oh, nice to meet you, Jennifer.
What are you gonna do with your grand?
- I'm probably going to
save it for my education.
- Oh, well that's good.
I was gonna say don't pay a bill with it,
but that's a good one actually.
But good luck on your education.
That's awesome.
- [Jennifer] Thank you so much.
- That's opportunity.
Thank you for coming.
- [Jennifer] Thank you.
- I'm so glad you, it looks
like you're still in shock.
So, I'm gonna not talk to you anymore.
Okay, well thank you, Jennifer.
Thank you to all our guests today.
Garth Brook, Kyle Chandler,
Ruby Bridges, Kenneth Gorham,
and our very own, Kevin Grace.
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not, well, try and change it.